Speaker 1: Okay. Let's hear from
more of the most important people.
The audience without the audience. I'm a guy
in a room with a microphone and it's really,
really sad. Let's go next to Dave
from Brooklyn. Dave, welcome.
Dave from Brooklyn, you're on the air. You
are muted. You've got to unmute yourself
in order to talk to me. And last call
for Dave from Brooklyn, who has muted
himself and Dave has quit. All right, let's go
to an old friend, Isa from London. Isa, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. Um, following on from what
I think it was John, he was talking about the.
The Kennedy brain case. Yes. So I'm an NFL fan
myself. Unfortunately, I'm a Cardinals fan. So
the season was spent in misery for the most part.
But I was thinking it's a bit strange how it's the
only sports league in the whole world, and I guess
the only sport in the whole world where religion,
specifically Christianity, seems to be, I
guess, ingrained in the culture. Hmm. Dude,
what do you think about that?
Speaker 1: Because you're saying
Christianity is ingrained in the NFL. How is that?
Speaker 5: Maybe maybe not in the NFL, but
even in college football and even in the
the high school level of the sport. Like
I heard about the majority of the players.
Being Christian. And I've heard instances
of daily practice and training sessions
where guys have prayer circles and it goes back to
that thing where you're expected to bow your head
and sort of just join in our respect. Yeah, and if
you don't, then that affects your social standing
within the squad and with the coach.
Speaker 1: Agree? Totally. I mean,
a lot of the top high school programs and college
programs are in some of the most religious parts
of the country. And that I absolutely agree with.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Yeah. Like Alabama and Clemson,
for example. Yep. Um, but then,
like, you know, guys like Tim Tebow
who obviously flopped, but then he went on Fox
and he was talking about his religious beliefs.
You know, I heard stories about
guys like him, for example,
when he was at the combine, before he joined
the league. Uh, he, there was some instance
where he said to everyone, Hey, guys, let's have
a prayer circle. And apparently he was laughed at.
But yeah, I think, I think it's just a bit
strange how, how much religion seems to be
ingrained in the the culture on and off the field.
Speaker 1: I agree with you. I mean, it doesn't
resonate with me, but it's you know, it it is what
it is. I think it is true that it is less present
in other major sports. I mean, you don't hear
about the big Christian presence in like soccer,
for example. You know, soccer is much smaller
in the United States also. But I agree with you
completely. To me, it's all a bit weird.
Speaker 5:
Yeah. Same.
Speaker 1: It's also just like
at the end of the day, is it that if both teams
pray and one team wins, did God choose that team?
Was it because they practiced more or because they
prayed more? I mean, it's always all a little bit
strange to me for that reason as well.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
Speaker 3: No.
Speaker 1: All right.
Things are otherwise good in London.
Speaker 5: Not really. No, but.
Speaker 1: Oh, what's going on?
Speaker 5: Well, I mean, you know,
if we if we were. Well, by the time the show is
like the latest affairs, we'll probably be out
date, you know, like something new each week.
Um, what's the most recent thing? Probably,
um, the, the U.K. Tories looking to
repeal a European based Human Rights
Act because they wanted to deport asylum
seeking immigrants to Orlando. Yeah, um,
I don't know if you heard about that.
Speaker 1: No, I did not. I
haven't been following that.
Speaker 5: Yeah. So there was
a plane. There was a plane ready to deport
them. Um, and then right at the last second,
the European based Human Rights Council blocked
it. So now they want to they want to repeal these.
These human rights laws so they can proceed
with basically deporting immigrants.
Speaker 1: Wow. So not that different than what
Republicans want to do here, it sounds like.
Speaker 5: Not really, no.
Speaker 1: Hey, Lisa, before I let you go. Can you
name three countries that start with the letter G.
Speaker 5: G. Yeah. Gabon. Gambia. Germany.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. All right. Thank
you, my friend. Good to talk to you,
too. All right. There's Lisa from London,
giving us a little trivia as well.